foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth to work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John deloney from the ever popular Dr
John deloney show on the Ramsay networks
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
mental health expert and so if you want
to talk about relationships and work in
some questions about all of that while
we talk about everything else here this
what this show is about you we're here
to serve you talk about you right in
front of you yup triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Andrea is with us in Houston hi Andrea
how are you
blessed and how ever how about
you just the same how can I help
I
I have long story short a year and a
half ago I got good and mad and decided
enough and I am fully focused on working
the baby steps
recently my sister had reached out to
all of us in the family brothers and
sisters that we should really get
together and come up with a plan for our
parents because unfortunately they've
always worked paycheck to paycheck they
have no savings
um my father he's 64 still working
full-time
I really can't see him even retiring
we've recently found out that he's
removed my mom from his insurance
because she refuses to provide any
documentation that he would need in
order to have her added and he's not
really pushing because he sees it as
well if she's not using it why even pay
for it
you're talking about health insurance
correct okay so what's your question
my question is my sister's idea was to
start a savings account where we all
contribute
roughly a hundred dollars a month for
them until the unforeseeable future
there's no end in sight for that and
she's just very sweet absolutely not
yeah absolutely not
no I just don't know what to do because
I feel that if
I kind of have the expectations of oh
it'll get better something will come up
why why would it get better they're not
changing anything
I know but in the end it'll come to us
I can't see what will come to you you
mean you got to feed them
medical expenses my mom
her mental health isn't that great
um she has her good days and bad days we
try to get her to go see a doctor but
she just gets irate refuses to listen
um
we just know that eventually it'll since
she won't go see a doctor it's gonna
it's not gonna be pretty when what about
your dad have you sat down with your dad
across from a table and said I'm coming
to you in love and
all of us here love you we know that Mom
is struggling mightily and we know that
it's very tough
but we're also looking at you're 63
can't do this forever
and I want to know if you guys have a
plan for what comes after this and I'm
asking this because I had this exact
conversation with my mom and dad
we've had the conversation with my dad
and he's kind of putting it on us
more of a well she's your mother of
worst case scenario you'll deal with it
and I have that with him and I'm I've
told them like we do need to come up
with a plan because in the end we'll be
in more debt than what we already are
you're not in debt
I am in debt you don't get there you
don't get their debt no cause she's got
her own debt I know but I'm saying
you're not gonna oh you're gonna go into
debt to help them no you're not yes
absolutely not
no I just wouldn't do it no
no we ask these people to help
themselves we offered to help them help
themselves and their answer was no
absolutely you're not going into debt to
help somebody poisoning your family tree
in order to help somebody who's poisoned
theirs is is that's how that's how
family trauma just rolls down a hill
it's just going to stay the same way and
your kids are gonna it's just gonna keep
going that way somebody's got to say I'm
done I'm out
so there is no amount of money that is
enough to take care of all of the
possible things that could happen to
these two people who refuse to take care
of themselves
and a hundred dollars a month is
laughable
I know that's a joke it's a joke it's
like everybody wants to feel like they
did something and you did nothing
that's twelve hundred dollars you know
how fast that goes 30 seconds in a
doctor's office it's gone that's how
much it costs to open those those those
those doors just to walk in if you walk
in the door they charge you 1200 bucks
just for coming
that's a year of you putting it in there
no absolutely not and you're going to
end up with an account that and brothers
and sisters arguing over who's doing
what who's doing what we're going to do
this I will manage my money I will
decide with my money and my wealth how
much help I'm going to be able and
willing to help with extended family
members including parents
you may have to decide you can't do
anything
you are not morally legally or ethically
obligated or biblically obligated to
write checks for these people that would
refuse to take care of themselves
okay you're just not I'm not saying I'm
not saying you shouldn't but I'm saying
the guilt-trip thing that is hovering in
this whole conversation is absolute bull
okay like we have to get together to
figure out how we're going to take care
of these people no we don't
no we don't
nope nope I can decide what I can do or
am willing to do you can decide what you
can do or you're willing to do but we're
not going to form a little GoFundMe 100
bucks a month that's a freaking joke and
feel like we did something nope nope
nope I'll pass so all you can do here is
what you've done and that is tell
everybody involved kindly and gently and
with compassion that you love them and
then when something comes up you decide
if you're able and willing to
participate you and your husband but you
do not destroy your family unit to pay
bills medical bills for someone had the
opportunity to get health insurance and
just didn't
no yeah
that's wrong it's wrong
and so you and your husband sit down and
say all right not if but when this
happens we will
mom can come stay in the garage
apartment or we're not going to move in
a position to do this and then like Dave
said you call your brothers and sisters
and you say this is what we're able to
do yeah and and I'm going to put a
period and remember always choose guilt
over resentment choose guilt or
represent you're going to feel guilty
that's that's that's normal you're going
to feel guilty your brothers and sisters
are going to do a great job of making
you feel guilty because they learned it
from their mom and dad
if you go along with this
and further put yourself in debt to
support somebody who is willingly is
looked at as kids and said ah y'all
carry this I don't I don't want to this
is y'all's problem I can't I can't
imagine as a dead day of doing that but
that's that's the world you're in
um
yeah it's very hard to walk through but
you have to establish some very firm
reasonable kind boundaries and then
protect your family out of abundance and
surplus you can help them to whatever
extent you want to without becoming an
enabler probably already too late this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsey Way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America
wow phone numbers triple eight eight two
five five two two five zaxon Huntsville
Texas hi Zach how are you
yeah I've been better uh-oh how can we
help
uh well Murphy kicked in my front door
asked me where's the beer and planted
his butt firmly on my couch and
on top of that I have some major
struggles with ADHD so I was hoping John
could help me figure out ways to stop my
impulse spending so that I can clean
this mess up because I'm
I'm completely alone in two things
number one I don't have accountability
partner because I'm single and number
two I'm a truck driver I'm on the road
all the time I don't have somebody
sitting next to me to tell me hey that's
stupid don't do that and I'm also a
master at talking myself into making the
stupid decision anyway so you're awesome
you're also a master at deflecting
responsibility
is that true too
uh
yeah answer yes I'm working on working
on getting better at it but you're not
wrong you can't even say the words
you're right you can't even say it
so if you Google ADHD my picture comes
up right so I'm gonna feel like you're
not I guess that's what I told you
um
ADHD is a context not an excuse
okay it is a brain processing issue I
say issue it makes some things harder
and it makes some things Inc way easier
than than people that you know and love
okay so I want to move that over to the
side I want to focus on the behaviors
that the actions that you're not doing
and that you are choosing to blame all
this stuff on
and this is what I'm trying to do is
Empower you and unchain you from this
you think this this adhd's dragging you
around the world making you do all these
things it's not it's not it's not true
it's contributing to the chaos in your
life 100 percent
that's not making you do things
you're not out of control
um the A and the ADHD is not in control
that's what John's saying
um unless you choose to hand over the
keys to the car
and let it drive
and that's a choice but you're not out
of control yes as I'm trying to be
intentional about things the very
concept of ADHD makes intentionality
difficult oh yeah man my wife calls I've
got magical time she calls it
um it's a very unintentional tuning out
like
it has happened this morning I went
downstairs to grab something out of the
uh small fridge we have in the garage
and on the way back up I thought
literally I haven't practiced this
guitar solo in a while and I went back
downstairs and went into the basement
the other part of the basement and got
my guitar and plugged it and this is at
6 15 this morning and then my kids are
upstairs I get what you're talking about
and that was all of those steps along
the way were choices I made
see what I'm saying hmm
yeah I I see what you're saying like uh
like I'm working really hard on the
impulse control because I recognize that
is a choice I'm making and I'm getting
better at stopping the only other facet
of it that has caused me the most
difficulty is forgetting things that
need to be paid on certain times because
like I do got a few roommates who help
me keep track of the bills but like
they'll call me like oh hey remember
this bill needs to be paid on Friday and
I'm driving so I can't like write it
down or nothing like that hold on hold
on you're trying to White Knuckle your
way through this there was a season and
I'm I'm not proud of this but this was
me taking ownership I gave my debit card
to my wife for a season years ago
I put as many roadblocks as possible
between my impulse issues and
the world I wanted to create I also have
I'm bad about firing off emails so I
made a rule I don't email for 24 hours
like I'm putting these barriers in front
of me and over time my body learns that
this is a better way to live yeah so in
other words
another way of saying that Zach is to
say we've got to put some processes in
place that remind you about the bills
whether it's a calendar system you're
using whether it's the every dollar app
then you put a reminder in about a bill
and it dings when you wake up in the
morning
you put a systems and processes in place
that do two things they spur you towards
proper actions at the proper times and
you can even put some processes and
systems in place that give some
boundaries to your purchase and it can
just be a a self-rule a rule is I don't
use Amazon Prime
because I can't control it a rule could
be that could be it may not be a rule
could be I'll give you a rule that I
give everyone that goes through
Financial Peace University if you're
going to spend over 500 on an item wait
overnight
because the body chemical the body
chemistry changes overnight
and so large purchases anyone regardless
of ADHD uh should wait overnight because
your your adrenaline drops the proteins
endorphins have been released you get
excited and the chemistry of excitement
occurs when you're making a purchase
there's all kinds of you can you can map
it on a graph and so you know if you
feel that that rising up inside of you
go wait I have to wait overnight that's
one of my rules and in my case I'm
married you're not you said but I also
have to talk to my spouse I don't spend
500 without talking to her she didn't
spend 500 without talking to me it's not
because I'm impact and my wife controls
my life or I'm an overbearing husband
and she can't do anything she's not got
any rights it's because we respect a
process that keeps us from overspending
I want you to get Upstream of this too
what is it what does that mean you gotta
exercise
even if it's if it's going for walks
before you hit the truck in the morning
you got to be conscious of what you're
eating you got to get sleep you gotta do
these things way Upstream that give your
brain a Fighting Chance
you can't sleep four and a half hours a
night drive 90 miles an hour for 12
straight hours crash in some dimly lit
uh hotel room eat something from the
continental breakfast and hit the road
again
it's like putting water and sand in your
gas tank the thing's not gonna run very
well
um
you there you there yeah yeah and uh as
uh ironically because of this call I was
going to ask a question I completely
forgot what oh yeah um like
any tips for trying to stop these small
ones because I've never done like
anything over like 100 or 500 or
anything like that
put a process in place where are you
buying them how are you buying it
usually it's like I'm grogging and
running a little late in the morning so
I go grab McDonald's for breakfast or I
have had a really long really hard day I
don't have the energy to want to cook
anything so I just walk inside and order
something from Carl's Jr it's usually
stuff like that so meal prep
go to the store and buy yourself a box
of protein bars put something ahead of
it and you're gonna have to be a
grown-up and say no to yourself and
that's hard that's hard here here's the
thing what you're describing is uh not
an ADHD thing it's an everybody thing
everyone when we get fatigued and time
stressed
always default to the point or to the
point of least resistance on food on uh
on purchases on everything and so uh
there's a great saying but Patton he
said uh fatigue makes cowards of us all
that you don't have much courage to
fight against yourself when you're tired
and so
um you know I discovered that you know
little thing and I've laughed about it
here on the air I gained a whole bunch
of weight during covet because I ate
every donut in a 50 mile radius so I
discovered that the stress of running
this place and keeping it open and
making payroll and keeping a thousand
people's jobs in place the stress of
fighting against entire segments of
Revenue evaporating and coming in here
and trying to replace it with our
leadership team and working working and
working and working and working I that I
gave myself permission to eat everything
in sight particularly donuts and so once
I got about halfway through that process
I realized
I'm going to die I have to stop this I'm
going to be as big as a freaking house
fat boy needs to stop eating Donuts I
just quit cold turkey I just quit
because I recognize that okay when I'm
tired when I'm working when I'm putting
in a 16-hour day that's when I'm
vulnerable when I'm traveling right
that's when I'm vulnerable because
fatigue is always with travel so I
recognize your points of vulnerability
pre-prepare like John said pre-preparing
meals but also just say okay
this is a time I screw up oh I'm not
gonna do that it's about changing
identity and pick up Gabor mate m-a-t-e
his book called scattered which is the
ADHD Masterpiece you can check that out
as well listen to it while you're
driving scattered
wow this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
exciting weekend here at Ramsey
all the Ramsay personalities including
Dr John deloney me Rachel Cruz George
Campbell Jade warshaw
uh Ken Coleman will all be doing the
smart conference this weekend in our
brand new Ramsey Event Center our first
public event there we are really excited
about it and folks call us all over the
place for advice about their money now
the smart conference this weekend is a
Friday night all day Saturday event it
is completely sold out sorry I'll just
hope you get some fomo we'll be
announcing soon another one coming up in
the fall but it won't be here so you
missed this one but maybe you didn't
because you could at least watch the
early morning or the first few Talks Of
The Morning Rachel Cruz George
Campbell's talk uh about how to get your
income up control your spending change
your mindset learn about money the first
couple of talks on Saturday morning we
are going to live stream them
free
the event is sold out we can't put
anybody else in the building so we can't
help any more people unless we do it
this way so don't keep living how you're
living jump on this live stream it's
free
sign up at ramseysolutions.com live and
we'll pipe it to you this coming Sunday
morning and Rachel Cruz and George
Campbell are both world-class
communicators actually all of our Ramsey
personalities are I'm very proud of them
and I'm more Regional class more
Regional I'm a regional class
I'm local
well I mean when you get into
self-deprecating you're the king but
other than that Regional class
yeah I don't know what Regional class
means
so anyway we're all going to be there
and we're all going to be excellent in
spite of John and so but if you want to
watch the first couple talks
ramseysolutions.com live for Saturday
mornings smart conference Rachel Cruz
George Campbell you want some help with
your money you want to be inspired you
want some information uh some
inspiration that you haven't had maybe
you know someone that does have them
sign up and watch this live stream it is
completely free for the first couple of
lessons on Saturday morning so budget
about an hour and a half or so two hours
and you'll be able to catch catch the
startup the Saturday morning startup of
the smart conference so thanks for
hanging out with us Bianca is in San
Diego hi Bianca how are you
hi I'm great thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
so my husband and I have about a 200k in
debt not including our mortgages we have
two homes one we live in and one that we
use as a rental
um we both are on board paying off debt
we're tired of paying in debt but we
have different paths that we think we
can get there faster so the home that's
our rental he had that previously before
he met me
um basically he took over it um from his
grandfather that was going to go into
foreclosure so that's how he has that
home I would personally want to sell
that home and use the equity in that
because now far dead and he's more
thinking he wants to keep that other
house and just be really intentional and
work more hours and pay it off um just
like gazelle intense so I kind of wanted
to give you that advice you have two
hundred thousand dollars in debt that is
not mortgages
yes on what
well it's one of your favorite words a
hundred thousand on HELOC which was a
bad idea we have 80k in student loans
and about 20 on solar nothing on cars
no card payments no okay what was the
HELOC for paying off old bills
when we purchased the home we basically
purchased this home that we're in now my
daughter has special needs and we needed
to get her into a better school district
and we basically bought like the ugliest
house on the nicest Street if that makes
sense so it needed like a full there was
like
um cracks everywhere in the concrete we
had to do a lot of upgrades to it to
just get it lovable
so this was for repairs
yes how much is your first mortgage
so the one
one yeah the one with the HELOC
yeah it's six hundred thousand what's
the house worth
um I just looked at Zilla today it's
worth 9.75 okay cool and the other house
that was his Grandpa's has how much owed
on it
350. and what is it worth
when I looked today it's worth 6 20.
okay and how long have y'all been
married
we've been married five years
[Music]
five years what's their household income
Tax Service I'm taking care of her right
now and we have a special needs daughter
so it's just his income
okay the house he got from his grandpa
that was in foreclosure was that a a
family property uh by that I mean does
it have
history with the family or was this just
a place Grandpa lived
um it's kind of a long story like kind
of messy but basically he lived there
and then he was going to lose it because
he made some bad financial investments
you told us it was in foreclosure well
does it have family history or not
yeah all of his his mom grew up there
his aunts everybody grew up in that
house
so really that's his reasoning for not
selling it not some kind of financial
decision
yeah I think I think there is an
attachment I think sometimes also he
thinks like oh you know we don't know
how our daughter our daughter is going
to develop and he thinks like the more
property and more stuff like income we
can uh generate for her yeah until you
took out a hundred thousand dollars of
HELOC to fix a cracked sidewalk
yeah yeah they kind of kind of screwed
that plan up
like I want to do something good for my
special needs daughter so we're going to
go deeply in debt no that that those two
things are counteract or
counterproductive he's got a really
expensive bucket bailing water on a ship
with a hole in it
he's a stop and plug the hole in the
show yeah you guys got to sell this
house you gotta sell the house
I'm sorry I hate it because it does have
memories and it is going to break a part
of his heart and that's why he doesn't
want to sell it but um you're uh needs
your daughter's needs the future of your
house is much more important than the
past of that other house
okay and another way another way to
think of it is
instead of trying to prop up this idea
of Legacy in in these four walls of this
house
be able to sit back and say my granddad
bought this house raised families here
and set us up in a position that we
could change our family tree when it
comes to our money you know and what's
your daughter's name
who needs um Natalya Natalya okay would
you do me a favor don't you ever blame
your stupid butt financial decisions on
your daughter again
okay that's so wrong
my special needs daughter gave me
permission to do stupid stuff no
you have an extra responsibility to not
do stupid stuff in the name of having a
special needs daughter
not I have a special needs daughter so
we had to do this if you keep using her
as a cloak for your stupid stuff you're
going to keep doing stupid stuff because
it gives you permission to do anything
if you call on the nobility of taking
care of special needs and that is not a
fact
so quit doing that you've got to stop
that and you guys have to get yourself
if you're going to sell this house and
pay off everything you've also got to
get on a budget you've got to get under
control you've got to make every dollar
behave because you'll go back into this
mess if you blame Natalya for your next
stupid thing again like this house you
bought that was all the pieces and then
you went in debt further after buying
the house
and and but used it all as a
rationalization to make that move and
you just can't do that you've get you
know next time you get ready to buy a
car we'll have a special needs daughter
I don't care
I don't care you still can't buy a car
if you can only have the money to buy it
you got to stop this you've got to stop
this
and and so you guys have got to get
yourselves under control the danger of
selling the house is you guys don't
change your decision-making processes
and your habits and you're going to go
back in debt but truthfully
mathematically you need to sell the
house you're right and get rid of all
this debt and get it off of you but only
if you both raise your right hand and
Pinky swearing spit shake to never make
decisions that involve debt again ever
and live on a written budget where you
live on less than you make and um listen
stuff comes at all of us
relatives get cancer people pass away
children have struggles stuff comes at
all of us you've got to have a process
that involves you to live your life
without sacrificing the quality of your
life on the altar of the bad things that
come at you
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
thank you for being with us if you're
brand new to the show and based on our
rankings and ratings we know a bunch of
you are lots of new folks coming around
thank you for that and those of you
telling people to come thank you for
that but if you're brand new and you're
trying to uh learn all this lingo and
what this Ramsay stuff means and all
that well uh go to the Ramsay site go to
ramsesolutions.com
ramseysolutions.com click on the get
started button and we'll help you figure
out the next best step for where you are
and start to kind of graft you in this
is where you are and here's the next
thing you can do and here's how we teach
this and it's all free all things free
so not a problem at all check it out all
right uh Jonathan's with us in Houston
Texas hey Jonathan how are you
I'm doing good Mr Ramsey I heard you've
been doing Finance for a while so I
thought maybe you'd be the guy to go to
for some advice
[Laughter]
since the dinosaurs roam their Earth
brother what's up
well um I am currently working three
jobs
um one full-time job one side gig and uh
also serve in the reserves
um my side gig at this point is making a
lot more than my full-time income and so
I am just hoping to get some advice on
when to pull the trigger and and make
that my full-time gig what is it
uh so the side gig is I make music
um it started on social media and has
grown in some other platforms
um the problem the hang up I have is
I've only been doing it about six months
so I'm just kind of worried about the
stability I have a wife and son and uh
just trying to make it all happen at
once all right I'm a little confused how
are you making music make money on
social media
you're just wildly popular
um it has kind of blown up uh but most
of my income is coming from the music
streaming platform Spotify Apple all of
that the social media is mainly just the
way I get it out there how much are you
making like give us real dollar amounts
not pretend musician dollars
yes sir
um I made about fifty thousand dollars
between August and December this last
year so I'm projecting maybe between 100
and 125 this year but was that on a
particular track that blew up or is that
a steady stream that's slowly increasing
over time you see I'm saying like is
that it I have a post that gets 300 000
likes on it and then my next one gets
six my next one gets two two two two so
I had I had one really cool thing happen
and then it just settles back in
yes sir uh so I thought that that's what
was going to happen to me um but each
thing that I've posted since then I've
got about 25 songs out now and they have
all been performing well I'm getting
good engagement so I I expect it to
continue to grow I've had one or two
that's maybe bigger than the others but
um it's been very consistent all in all
so all of your revenue is coming from uh
your your
uh letting people sample the song on
social and then they're going to iTunes
and buying it and for a buck for a buck
you're making 50 Grand
uh yes sir I would say the streams are
probably
um close to 70 percent
um of that income the rest comes from
just ad share on the social media uh
site uh selling CDs and and that sort of
thing how many followers have you got
uh between all I'm approaching a million
I think I'm about 900 000.
you're not getting much rev share then
okay uh a little but you know you're the
main thing is you're just monetizing
your music career beautifully
congratulations highly unusual and
wonderful okay here's the thing here's
what we're poking around on and you're
asking so
um
if if the if the side is this
replicatable and sustainable can I
repeat the process can I keep making can
I use this recipe to keep making cakes
because the cake I made is sold but can
I use this recipe to keep making enough
cakes to feed my family that's what
we're trying to figure out is it
sustainable and scalable and you know
can you get bigger and bigger and bigger
so certainly uh you've done you've done
an amazing job so far congratulations
that's fabulous oh I would not quit my
day job and except to the extent that
you can
prove to yourself logically and you and
your spouse are you married
yes sir yeah you and your spouse are
saying they're looking at this going
okay is this a recipe that if I keep
using this recipe I'm going to keep
getting quality chocolate cake in other
words I'm going to keep making money
doing music uh and that's what we were
poking out trying is this a one hit
wonder okay you've established this knot
or by I'm buying that okay that's good
um and and then at what point can we
level in and go okay this is music
business is my career because there's a
whole lot of wannabes in that space and
not many people who actually make a
living yeah and the space is littered
with a great first record or I finally
got I finally got a feature film so I
quit my day job and went and I I did a
good job I got a good in I got a good
role in this film
and then there's no more films what do
you do what do you do during the day
I'm in construction I do estimating
okay for a general contractor okay and
how much of that do you have
uh make about 70
um over there and that the thing is I
really like that job how much debt do
you have I'm just letting myself dry oh
um I just my house own a house that's it
okay does your wife work outside the
home
uh no sir she started staying home this
year okay all right so you're bringing
you're bringing in about 120 and we're
talking about cutting that to 50 but
you'd have more hours so maybe you could
get the 50 up to 70. if the recipe is
duplicatable
if you had more hours to work on the
music because you didn't have a
construction job
you know could you get it up to 70 or
even 90 but you're still taking a pay
cut net net because you're giving up the
day job right
uh Matt I will take a pay cut however I
am making more on a monthly basis doing
the music I'm grossing about 10 to 12
000 per month probably on average okay
yeah but gross is not
um I mean you mean gross of taxes or
gross of expenses
I'm bringing in about ten thousand
dollars on the music I may have a
thousand or two in expenses yeah mixing
gross doesn't matter net matters plus 30
that you're gonna have to pay in time
put aside for taxes yeah but the uh um
and then insurance if you're if your GC
pays you your health insurance or
something you're going to have to budget
that into yeah so the to the extent that
you can see this is replicatable
sustainable and can be grown
is when I'm comfortable with that I'm
going to quit
and do what you're doing okay
that's what I would do yes sir so that
that's uh but that you've re you're
really in a position to ascertain that
better than and be sure
that you don't talk your wife into this
be sure that she says honey you've got
to do this this is the right thing I
have here's what you really want to hear
from her I have peace about this
if your wife says that you're probably
on track
yes sir but if she's like I'm scared
don't do it
and it's not because she's a scaredy cat
because here's the thing proverbs 31
says who can find a virtuous wife for
her worth is far above rubies the heart
of her husband safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain
when I stopped making decisions that
went against the peace in my wife's
Spirit my income went up substantially
our asset base went up substantially the
number of stupid butt things that we did
went down substantially now is she
without error no of course she's not
without error and she will tell you that
because she's a virtuous
woman
she will tell you sometimes she makes an
error I'm not sure if this is the holy
spirit honey it could be last night's
pizza but I don't feel good about this
she's not saying and thus saith the Lord
or thus saith the wife she's not
confused she's not confused her own
voice with the voice of the Holy Spirit
and some people do that
so yeah you just get you know you've got
to kind of she's got to have that peace
if she's got that peace she's looking at
the systems my wife let me tell you John
my wife says she has a feeling or from
East Tennessee a feeling
this is so syllable word if she's got a
bad feeling we're about to lose 10 grand
minimum I fought my wife on this for the
first half of our marriage and she is
even sophisticated enough now to say I
don't like this but it's right go forth
right like I I feel in my spirit yeah
trust it 100 yep I don't I don't know if
I don't quite understand it but it feels
right that's right that's a that's a
that's a deal right there this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for being with us America it's a free
call a triple eight eight two five five
two two five Sebastian starts off this
hour in Canada hey Sebastian welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey how's it going better than I deserve
how can I help
uh so I'm a 35 year old uh married four
kids
uh I recently bought a new house uh
maybe three years ago paid cash uh 100
no 928 000.
I make 80 000 a year
and uh
I have a lot I have a couple houses in
real estate and
my question is should I
try to pay down those mortgages in that
my tenants are technically paying for or
should I try to
invest for my retirement
yes
you should do both
and by the way tenants don't technically
pay for anything they maybe pay their
rent and then you maybe can use that
money to pay your payments
so um only beginner landlords say things
like the tenants pay the rent because
those of us that have owned rental
property for a few decades know that
that's a sham
so um anyway the uh so you own two
properties that you have dead on how
much do you owe on those two properties
no I I I own six properties six
properties I'm sorry okay and you have
how much debt on those six properties
1.2 million so on average of 200 000 a
piece okay and you and you make eighty
thousand a year
yeah
okay
where did you get the 900 000 to pay
cash for your house
I always had a tent in my basement when
I when I first bought my house at 18
years old and then I just paid off my
house within maybe six years and then I
did uh upgrades in my house and then I
sold out for roughly 865. okay my first
house was like sold off and then good I
paid that one cash excellent this is
sounding like a breaking bad situation
okay I'm glad you I'm glad you figured
that out okay so we're out of there and
we got the how and we've got a nice paid
for home you got a net worth in excess
of a million dollars very well done and
you're you said you're how old
35. good job very good job Sebastian
well I'll tell you what I would do and
that's why you called us what would I do
if I woke up in your shoes I own
um several hundred million dollars worth
of real estate I love real estate I
think it's a wonderful investment
um and so uh I'm with you on the real
estate and you've done good on real
estate you've made money on real estate
so that's all good what you don't want
to do is uh
fail to realize that debt equals risk
more debt equals more risk less debt
equals less risk no debt equals no risk
at least of that type of risk and so
what I would do is I would start working
to get those uh paid off you don't have
to panic to do it but don't just sit
there and pay the payments let's figure
out a way any extra cash we find let's
start throwing it at those while you're
working the baby steps now your baby
steps are uh you're out of debt
everything but the houses and you are
that aren't you
yeah I don't have any good and you have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses that is your rainy day fund
and then once you've got the emergency
fund in place of three to six months of
expenses then you should start here's
the answer to your question 15 of your
income going into retirement and uh in
Canada you've got the equivalent of a
401k type retirement that you can choose
good mutual funds in and I'll be putting
15 of my income into that and then money
I can find on the table I'm going to
begin to clear This 1.2 million in my
case I have prospered so greatly
because I have no debt
so all the rents I get to keep
all the income minus the expenses of
operating the property I get to keep I
don't have to send it to the bank
and so the tenants are paying me they're
not paying the bank so it makes sense I
might sell a few of them I was gonna say
I sell two or three of them and pay off
the other two or three and yeah out of
the six I'm gonna pick out my least
favorite two that have sweet Equity but
I don't think they've got as good a
future as the other four I want to look
at the four and say you know 20 years
from now these four are in great
neighborhoods I'm gonna love owning
these houses for 20 years but these
other two yeah not so much
there's a few cars up on blocks on that
street or whatever it is right I'm not
that is that one's not going to
appreciate as much I'm dumping those two
throwing the equity at trying to get the
first one of these paid off and then I
would snowball these rentals I would
list the debts smallest to largest not
throw everything at that smallest debt
rental then at the next smallest debt
rental and when you get them all clear
dude you're going to have an emotional
experience you don't see coming because
you have quit measuring risk in your
emotions you don't feel it you're numb
to it you're you're used to it you've
become satiated to it and when it goes
away You're Gonna feel like someone
lifted a 300 pound weight off your back
I actually wonder if that's why he
called because he's got a million dollar
paid off house and then all of a sudden
he's quietly racked up 1.2 million
dollars he leveraged himself completely
yeah and you just don't sleep you don't
breathe it's if you're smart but I mean
sometimes you can become psychotic about
it I mean you can really I was my risk
leader meter was completely removed when
I was 16.
right after right after my wisdom teeth
and so I don't measure risk I I I had to
reinstall it with as a spiritual
experience
to say Okay God says the borrower is
slave to the lender I'm not going to be
a slave anymore reinstall the risk meter
I had to make a conscious Act of my will
to reinstall that because real estate
people one of the things they do they
take your risk meter out when you take
the test they just hit it with a hammer
and then hand it back to you you know
you just you're just like oh the tenants
pay the bill and let's flip that on its
head I've got the exact problem on the
opposite side of the scale and so the
parable of talents I I have a tendency
to go bear everything in the backyard
and just sit and wait for the end times
and I have to be responsible Steward of
the gifts in front of me and do
something with them yeah act like you're
going to live yeah yeah you gotta you
gotta invest like you're going to live
and uh you got to invest in such a way
as if things go wrong sometimes because
they do hello that's the risk meter
right and so yeah if I'm in your shoes
I'm going to pick out the worst two
clear them and then use my income and
the increased income of the others to uh
by a couple of them now paid for and
knock the others out and have like a
three to a five your plan of having them
all paid for and I think you can do that
if you're careful that's what I would do
I think 15 years from now you're gonna I
know
15 years from now you're going to end up
in a better position than you would if
you try to hold on to these and White
Knuckle your way through it is there any
sort of
um recommendation for somebody he's got
a lot of house with a and I know he owns
it all he's got a lot of house for a
little salary and I know the idea is
like I paid cash for it but man you're
going to be spending a significant
amount of your salary just an upkeep on
a million dollar property like that just
on your house but maybe not maybe you
own it you own it and you own it right
that doesn't bother me as much as the
other parts of this one I'm more worried
about the million too than I am in that
house I think that house if it was two
million I might be going yeah that's
probably pull out a house yeah but this
this is you know
I'm good with that part this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back Ed by their
wash and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality host of the Dr John deloney
show if you've not tuned into his
podcast you need to it's pretty fun and
you'll learn some stuff about yourself
and about others and about relationships
it's good stuff number one best-selling
book own your past change your future as
well and John you have a big hit on your
hands uh these questions for human cards
there have become a a thing they are
definitely a thing having a blast
they're selling like crazy yeah yeah and
uh why do we need questions for humans
cards because we
have lost this skill am I going to say
it's a character issue or some kind of
if you're a loser we've lost the skill
of being in the presence of other real
humans and
not waiting for our turn to speak but
actually listening to somebody and
actually posing good questions and
engaging in dialogue we still know how
to do it anymore and that's fine that's
where we are let's figure it out yeah
so because I my guess is we've learned
to text we text each other we email each
other we we don't fight each other we
argue we focus down each other we have a
lot of arguments
especially on social media where we have
much more courage and here's another
crazy thing um that's that's emerged the
number of parents who thought that their
kids don't want to talk to them
or the number of kids who think my
grandparents don't want to talk to me or
my parents just don't want to interact
with me and so you've got people passing
each other in the night and parents
would do anything to sit down and have a
great conversation with a kid parents I
mean kids would do anything to have
parents put their stupid phones down
look them in the eye and ask them
um some deep important questions all
right just some fun questions some
laughter questions so
um that's what these questions for
humans are doing man and it's it's it's
it's been incredible I I never in a
million years would have anticipated the
response yeah the sales are off we have
trouble keeping them in the stock but
we've got them and we've got decks for
everyone if you're dating if you're a
married couple if you've got a girls
night event a guys night event parents
and kids friends Edition and they're
flying off the shelves and so it's just
a conversation starter and they're a lot
of fun again a lot of them are humorous
a lot of them are stuff you know what's
your first car what's the dumbest thing
you ever did in high school what are all
this kind of stuff right so all these
decks will get you spending time
laughing and learning and actually
looking at each other instead of screen
so pick up one two or even more of the
questions for human conversation cards
conversation starters a little deck of
cards is what they are and you can get
them at ramseysolutions.com
humans and notice it's not an app it's
not an app it's a physical product with
your screen it's not on your phone yes
it's humans looking at other humans
I just think that's an important thing
yeah yeah we actually toyed with that
man because it'd be so much easier
cheaper just to throw it online and but
man there's something powerful about
putting your phones in your purse or in
your in your back pocket and pulling
these things out yep yep yep yep yep
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five Colby is in
Greenville South Carolina hi Colby how
are you
can I call sure
um so my husband and I are in baby steps
four five and six
we have two kids and we are really
wanting to also pay off our mortgage so
we're wondering how do we split um like
our extra income between 529 investing
for our boys and paying off our home
there's no perfect formula but what I
have always done when I'm working with
customers like you or I'm looking at it
for myself is I I'm trying to say okay
how old are these kids and how much have
I got to have to get them going into
college I gotta at least have a good
start there right I gotta I gotta see a
way they can go to school debt free and
so if you've got a three-year-old
and you want to do 50 a month for now
and then attack the mortgage a little
more aggressively fine if you've got a
16 year old and you got no money for
their college you're probably not
putting anything towards the mortgage
much right now because you're probably
going to be trying to load catch that
war chest up that's really really thin
does that make sense
it does yes it and and and or I gotta
have a plan I gotta have a way I'm gonna
get there my husband was in the military
my wife was in the military so I got GI
bill or I've got this or I've got that
but the plan can't be student loans
right
so how old are your kids and how many
um two four years old and one year old
and what's your household income
it should be about 200 this year and how
much do you owe on your home
okay if I were in your shoes I would set
up 50 to 100 a month with my smart
investor Pro on each of these kids in
their 529s just to check the emotional
box and start to build the muscle that
I'm actually saving for college but
we're really not saving much money right
now and then I would use your fabulous
income and pay off this tiny little
mortgage you have really fast and then
you can Circle back and easily finish
out funding the college you got plenty
of Runway here I have plenty of plenty
of uh yeah Runway
and I'll tell you I I think and Dave
tell me if I'm wrong here but the fact
that you can get this thing paid off in
two years 18 months I love the idea of
almost deciding
let's be just a hair under a gazelle
intents and just to get this thing done
and then let's let's live our let's have
a fun life that's what me and my wife I
mean I I like that plan if you can do it
in this tiny little window there's
something about it let's just Sprint and
get it done yeah it's right the Finish
Line's in sight you can do a lot of
stuff you know it's uh you find energy a
burst of energy of the last Last Mile of
the race so that you can do that that
that's good there's nothing wrong with
that at all
um the whole thing is just be thoughtful
and I I would not ever tell you to do
zero towards kids college because I want
you to start building that muscle and
start have that system and process in
place even though mathematically we're
not really doing that much yet
okay it's kind of like when you first
start giving sometimes you start giving
a small amount to start to build your
generosity muscle and then over time
you'll increase your giving to uh to a
much greater think of it this way it's
about the identity shift we talk about
I'm a person who saves for my kids
college and it might just be 50 bucks
this time because I'm also a person that
doesn't owe anybody anything we're going
to Sprint towards that yeah it's just an
identity
yeah instead of I'm a person who gives
yeah and
the other thing is we are going to see
in this coming
15 years
uh uh more of a an upheaval in higher
education than in any 15-year period in
recent memory I 100 agree with that yeah
there's going to be a price War there's
going to be a a come to Jesus with the
culture on quit teaching stupid butt
stuff that's not usable in the
marketplace uh there's going to be
people are going to quit I hope they
quit paying for Prestige that doesn't
have any results
um uh you know we we have taken the
for the last many 15-year periods we
have taken the uh
the the common sense off of Education
yeah we've lost our we're dumb about
education which is actually an irony of
irony we've made it about dollars and
cents instead of Common Sense well not
even I mean we don't even look at the
dollars a sense we just go whatever it
costs and uh no I'm not seeing us I'm
seeing the business oh yeah they they
the higher ed that people did they're
they're cleaning up so uh all of you
ought to be watching borrowed future our
award-winning documentary there's one of
the top documentaries your before last
and uh still very valid but um you're in
good shape you're in good shape you're
going to be just fine Colby you're doing
all the right stuff but um the the Epic
student loan crisis is not over yeah we
continue to make the stupid student
loans everybody's talking about around
about how bad they are we ought to
forgive them but we keep making keep
doing it man which is so intellectually
dishonest it's unbelievable but that's
the definition of Congress
intellectually Dishonored and so you
know if Congress had had you know if you
really cared about America you just quit
making these loans that are destroying
America I mean it's just dumb you're
killing the Next Generation and the Next
Generation
they made an announcement I've been
thinking about how do you how do you
unwind this even if they made an
announcement kind of like they they made
an announcement about
um
in 2020 whatever we we expect this many
electric vehicles and in 2020 whatever
we expect this much water reduction
whatever
if you said in five to seven seven years
we're done College y'all have seven
years to figure this out you got five
years you got three years to figure out
your life without this but we're gonna
stop putting these loans out that's more
likely than
doing what I would do which is just shut
up shut the spigot off yeah I'll just go
yeah y'all had enough
y'all got enough it's good we're good
now figure it out yeah but I that
probably is not going to happen so
you're okay don't you don't have to
panic entire college towns would dry up
yeah I did that so that's probably not a
good idea this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money today's
question is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services here at
Ramsey we believe in making home
ownership a blessing and not a burden so
we recommend neighborly's network of
service professionals to repair maintain
and improve your home find the help you
need at neighborly.com all right today's
question comes from Andy in Virginia
when I get closer to retirement how do I
access the money in my retirement funds
do I take a set amount each month do I
only take money made off interest and
leave the principal alone how do I make
the money last
um that's that's the question Dave and I
love I love the
simp simplistic mechanistic question
here man how do I do this
well you can set it up with your broker
you have mute the money in the mutual
funds hopefully in your 401k your Roth
IRAs that kind of thing you decide which
um of your different retirement accounts
because most people aren't going to end
up with more than one retirement account
you may have a 401k from an old job you
may have Roth IRAs that you did your
wife might have had a 401k rolled over
those are all different buckets of money
you say okay out of those buckets of
money we're going to draw on this many
we're going to draw this much and you
can set a set amount and say I'm going
to draw this amount I'm gonna draw five
thousand dollars a month or you can say
I'm going to pull a percentage
a month
or you can say I'm going to pull the
gains
I would not say I'm going to pull the
gains if you've got the money invested
in good growth stock mutual funds that
have a track record
that's 10 to 12 percent
if you pull off
10 percent of it or eight let's say you
pull off eight percent of it
and it makes a 12 then you've left four
in there if it makes 10 you left two in
there
so it's going to be growing forever
you're not only not hitting the
principle you're not uh it is continuing
to grow so it will run in perpetuation
if you do that so in other words if the
the percentage that you're pulling off
is less than the percentage average
percentage of growth then you're going
to come out so over a 10-year period of
time if it averages growing 10 to 12 and
you pull off eight every year you're
going to not have touched the principle
at all in the end
you will have I will have grown now it
might or might not have kept up with
inflation but you know if you've got a
million dollars and you're pulling off
eight percent that's 80 000 bucks a year
and that's you know that's how you live
and so oh you pull out a lump sum does
it come out monthly set it up monthly
just get a monthly check on it eight
percent divided by 12 and just have that
amount coming out I want eight percent
of the thing coming out to me
um or you can say look there's a million
dollars there so I'm gonna I'm gonna say
eighty thousand bucks and have a monthly
check come on 80 000 bucks a year it's
whatever that happens and uh or I'm
gonna pull 40 000 bucks on uh five
hundred thousand that'd still be eight
percent and so you know that that or you
know I don't quite want to do that so
I'm going to pull thirty six thousand
which is three thousand dollars a month
no I have three thousand dollars a month
coming off and it'll last forever if you
do that what about a mandatory
disbursement if you have the required
minimum distributions that begin at 73
on traditional IRAs and traditional
401ks if you're doing this you will
easily meet that okay you will easily
meet that so it's not a problem at all
if they're Roth IRAs they don't have
that
let's say you're in a situation
um like you Dave and you've got some uh
um rental properties that are generating
cash flow you're you're not technically
working anymore but you're still money's
getting deposited and now you have this
mandatory withdrawal that you have to
make can you take that money out and
just reinvest it
it becomes taxable when you take it out
the purpose of them making you take it
out is so they can tax it send you some
money from you yeah that so you're going
to take it out it's a taxable event so I
have this income now what do I do with
that money you can do whatever you want
to do with your money you can invest it
you can give it you can do whatever you
want to do with it but it's it's coming
out and you're going to pay taxes on the
required minimum distribution beginning
at age 73. so either way uh except for
that part where uh it's like me and I'm
not working because I still work
correct yeah just to be clear okay
I was pretending you were 73. oh
how do you know I'm not working when I'm
73.
well
that's only 10 years
this is an uncomfortable conversation
John I think it's very comfortable one
of us is living in reality
you're thinking I'm going to be playing
more Golf and spending more time in Cabo
that's what you're I think you're gonna
be 73. I can I'm just saying that's how
that works all right Joanne is with us
in Boston Joanne get us out of this how
can we help
hi Dave thank you thank you for taking
my call sure
um I have a question should I
um sell my house and downsize I'll give
him my numbers I'm 59 I'm single my
salary is 152k my house is worth 9.50 I
owe 380.
um and also I had 401K it's 415 in the
401K and my savings 20K
why would you sell your house
that's a good question there's a couple
reasons I live in Massachusetts I just
unremote and I was thinking to go
Southern New Hampshire and get away from
some of the taxes
okay so you you wanna
downsize just yeah you're thinking
you're going to move to a different
state
yes which is only 20 minutes
yeah that close yep yeah and I was also
thinking now I'm 59 yeah I'm single and
I have to mow the lawn and do the yard
work well if you bought a house in
Jersey would you not have to mow the
yard lawn oh I was thinking a Townhomes
I wouldn't have so that's why the thing
but yes okay so you're thinking of
getting something that helps you get rid
of the maintenance it's a little newer
in a better tax situation
yes
yes if you spent exactly the same money
it'd be a net
a net gain in lifestyle
and no change in your finances
right I was thinking get smaller yeah if
you move down then it's kind of a net
gain and uh but there's you you don't
have to do this for your finances your
finances are not out of control but
you're wanting a better quality of life
by moving down
well that's kind of a no-brainer do it
yeah I mean you're you're not gonna
you're not going further in debt you're
not going to bankrupt Yourself by doing
this you're going the other way you're
going to free up money uh have a lesser
mortgage which you could get paid off
going into retirement which is the thing
you need to be doing you need to be
aiming at getting that paid off so if
you bought a townhouse in Jersey what
would it cost she's going to New
Hampshire oh New Hampshire I'm sorry
what would it cost I keep sending you to
Jersey I didn't you did something wrong
apparently but
um probably it looks like 550.
instead of 9.50
yeah
yeah I can get a town over there I've
been looking so you're paying cash
yeah
yeah I'm doing this for sure move
tomorrow
yes
that because if you got no house payment
now we're going to pile up cash even
more so let's play this out you got 450
in your 401k
and now you got no house payment and you
said your household income is 152 you're
single right
yes okay so the 450 if it's invested in
good mutual funds in your 401k if it's
not make sure it is we'll double about
every seven years you're 59 and a half
when you're 66 that's 9.50
okay so when you're 73 that magic number
that all those two old people those old
people shut up John it's two million
dollars
yeah okay so when you're 73 if you've
got this invested in good mutual funds
you're going to have two million dollars
if you add nothing to your retirement
and a paid for house you have no bills
yeah
I think we call that a touchdown in the
Super Bowl
yeah I think so too yeah and you're
going to be adding even more to it so
you're going to have four million
dollars that's going to be fun yeah this
is great this is great this and and you
don't have to cut the grass there I mean
there's all these benefits there's all
these and like that because those old
people came in New Hampshire yeah that's
it she's going to be getting it and you
won't be in New Hampshire and that's
you're being I mean you won't be in New
Jersey you'll be in New Hampshire
instead so there you go
I was trying to send her there I really
was you were trying hard I think I think
uh
I think it was Alzheimer's no I I think
in addition to being really good with
numbers you are also a geography Savant
that's outstanding
outstanding and sarcasm
gift there it is it's just over there
and it's cold it's north and there's
taxes go Celtics and Yankees yeah that's
right that's right
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today Sue is
with us in Tampa Florida hi Sue welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you for taking my call to both
of you
um my husband and I are in baby step
seven and he's 63 I'm 61. currently I'll
be retiring from my job in July when I
turn 62 and at that point we'll have an
uh surplus of about twenty five hundred
dollars a month and was just wondering
since we're in baby step seven we still
fully fund our envelopes we contribute
to our four grandchildren's savings
accounts for college
um we have the
um the thinking funds for a car what do
we do with that extra 2500 a month
what's your household income
after July it will be 80 81 000 a year
um there's no wrong answer uh generally
what I always try to do when I find
quote extra money laying around is I try
to stay I'm going to divide it some way
among three areas I'm going to invest
some I'm going to increase my generosity
some and I'm going to enjoy some
and uh like like when I'm working with
uh if I sit down with a like a
professional athlete let's say a
football player that's making 10 million
a year
and uh what we tell them to do is to set
a basic budget
maybe 100 150 000 a year to live on and
then everything above that let's break
it down into percentages and say okay
this percentage we're going to enjoy
this percentage we're going to invest in
this percentage we're going to be
generous with and that's what Sharon and
I do when we get an extra check in say
from a publisher maybe I get a royalty
check from an old book I wrote back in
the old days I still get those checks
that's extra money it's found money
we've already got percentages that we
applied to it for generosity enjoyment
and additional investing and of course
you've got to set your taxes aside so
what we do in our case is I won't give
you the exact percentages but I will
tell you that my taxes are 40 on
everything because I'm rich and I must
be punished that's like a Washington DC
rule right so
um so I got to pay 40 tax I'm an
Evangelical Christian so I tithe 10 on
all of my incomes so that's 50 40 and
10. then the other 50 I I automatically
set those two aside because I got those
are just automatic then the other 50 I
put some towards investing a percentage
some towards enjoyment which allows me
to buy some ridiculously wonderful
things and to go to some ridiculously
wonderful places
and uh uh it's just crazy and it doesn't
even take a high percentage to do it but
then of course also increase generosity
increase investing so enjoyment
generosity investing always be doing
those three things and also John that's
even where you start teaching a
two-year-old a five-year-old I was just
about to say um I I tell this story not
not for the praise but just to give a
picture
um one of my favorite things to do when
we have quote unquote found money we
have money that's in excess of our
budget Hank and I have breakfast and I
got this idea from you and Daniel like
we have breakfast every Tuesday morning
and we go to Waffle House and teaching
him the experience of comically over
tipping and watching the waitress's eyes
light up and sometimes they'll put the
lean on something because they need like
that that was a light bill right my son
now is so excited I'm having to hold
like hey man like that's you can't tip a
hundred and fifty percent on it right
he's bringing his own money because he
he wants to participate in that and now
you're Shifting the whole family tree
and so when you get 2500 bucks how fun
would it be to go on a date and go
somewhere nice and then just absolutely
take care of somebody in a in a magical
way one do it once a month walk through
the kitchen and hand out hundred dollar
bills yeah I'll leave man I mean after
after you had a wonderful dinner you
know that kind of stuff it's and you got
to remember when you're making 2500 when
you have 2 500 extra bucks it's easy to
separate yourself from that waitress
that is uh like a a a piece of dental
floss away from it off on in on 100
bucks makes a huge difference sometimes
it could be a great gift absolutely so
yeah the increased generosity and that
you can include that in tipping if you
want or random acts of generosity walk
around the gas pumps and pay for people
and just to watch their minds be blown
and uh you know buy a car for somebody
yeah you know it's just that you can buy
two thousand dollar car change
somebody's life it's crazy you can buy
10 of them for twenty thousand I mean
it's it's just a lot of fun so it's the
most fun you have with money but you
need to be doing all three you need to
have some enjoyment you need to have
some generosity some increased enjoyment
some increased lifestyle some increased
uh generosity all of those things that's
a really good question Sue so just sit
down and say okay out of my you said she
had 2500 is that what she said extra 2
900 what is if I'd give a number to it
I'm going to put 500 to this I'm gonna
put a thousand of that and I'm gonna put
500 you know whatever it is and had it
up and make but every dollar still has
an assignment
uh oh and guess what when you're
enjoying the enjoyment portion
knowing that you've been Noble with your
generosity and knowing that you've been
wise with your investing increases the
enjoyment of the enjoyment portion
because there's no regret there's not
that little voice saying you can't
afford this you can't afford this and
there's not a little voice saying you're
you're selfish you're evil yeah you're
evil because you have a nice car you
should you know you should you're going
to hell
because everyone knows
that could not that Christians don't
drive nice cars correct because I mean
it's the proper car is a 1974 Honda
Accord because the Bible says in Jesus
said and they were all in one Accord
right so there you go and uh so
otherwise you're going to hell right so
um but no I mean it's just ridiculous
that's the way people think out there
and so and and it also removes you from
all the Judgment of all the guilt
Trippers like uh because no one has any
concept of the of of what someone else
does with generosity
unless they just Crumpet every single
thing they do and then it's not
generosity it's it's ego right if you're
right-handed know what your left hand's
doing man then people aren't going to
know and they're gonna judge you and
that's fine that's on them yeah I'm
gonna sleep well at night yeah just you
know at your funeral and as you walk
into the Pearly Gates there'll be two
additional parties for all the people
that you blessed over the years that's
how that works and um because you know
there'll be people walking up to your
grandkids going yeah no idea what your
grandmother did that that that happened
with my grand I get joked up here that
happened with my granddad people showing
up out of the woodwork saying oh man
your granddad send us 500 up bucks back
in the 80s when we couldn't breathe and
yep we were able to fill in the blank
like that and he didn't make a lot of
money man so it was just a way of being
it's the best investment on the planet
all right Kevin is with us in Greenville
South Carolina hi Kevin how are you
hey Dave good afternoon good afternoon
Dr John deloney
um Bobby real quick I just wanted to
give you guys a call and ask you a
question Dave I uh I had a buddy I'm
hoping you can help me solve an argument
that I had with a buddy here that I
talked to abramsey with a lot
um he was telling me that uh that you uh
we I work for a large car manufacturer
in Greenville South Carolina I'm pretty
sure you can guess which one BMW and uh
yeah maybe
and so we have a lease program an
associate lease program it's fabulous
right now I'm looking yeah so that's
funny that you say that because he told
me Dave Ramsey recommends leases and I'm
like no I don't I don't recommend
leashes but your BMW lease programs for
employees is not a car lease it's an
employee benefit
okay a car lease is a car lease as you
get screwed if you go to the BMW
dealership and you lease a BMW you're
getting screwed it's a horrible plan but
you have an employee benefit that they
pay for your tires your gas your
insurance they pay for everything and it
costs you almost nothing to drive this
car comparatively to driving your own
car
yeah and the thing that bugged me was
the car payment but you know I mean it's
still a payment that we have to pay yeah
but if you listen if you just break okay
let's say you go about 25 000 car let's
pretend you're out and Dad and you had
extra money okay if you've got a 25 000
car and you're driving it around for the
gas that you would pay a payment on you
got to pay the gas payment to the gas
pump you've got to buy tires you've got
to change the oil you've got to buy
insurance and the stupid 25 000 car is
going down in value every day you own it
okay those are all payments too
okay you're just not writing one check
for all of them in this case you're
you're getting the use of a vehicle with
everything furnished am I am I correctly
uh outlining your employee benefit
yes you are okay it's a deal I would do
that deal if I work for BMW because
you're not borrowing money they're
giving you an employee benefit for a set
number of dollars a month that you can't
possibly drive a car anywhere near that
nice for that amount of dollars it's a
bargain but it has nothing to do with
leasing a car they call it a lease but
it's not even lease you can turn it in
each month
it's not even that you're not stuck in
it you get fired you're out of it it's
easy so it's not that it's a whole
different program this is the Ramsay
show
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage of Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jeremy is with us in Virginia Beach hi
Jeremy welcome to the Ramsay show hey
John and Dave thanks for having me I'm a
big fan of both of you guys well thank
you how can we help
well my wife and I have about 38 000
left on our mortgage uh we should have
it paid off in about 10 months
and we're super gazelle intense but I'm
curious
how should we start taking steps to draw
it back a little bit to maybe relax
after we pay off the house
um should I tell my employer that I'm
debt free and that I no longer want to
work overtime work on weekends or
should I even tell my boss at all that
I'm totally debt free
I I wouldn't be passing out my
net worth information to my boss but
that's just me
I work at a place where we do that all
the time but it's different what how
long have you been on this debt-free
journey
uh about three and a half years
and that did you have Consumer Debt
before you started paying off your house
here's what I'm asking
if you pay if you spent two years paying
off Consumer Debt and they just kept
going through your house it's a recipe
for Burnout that's why we tell people to
slow down when you get to your house and
breathe a little bit actually buy a bed
frame maybe or uh actually go out to eat
every once in a while or something like
that
um but you sounds like you've been
running the whole way through
yeah it's just been our house so we
bought the house when we were 21 uh
we're 23 and 24 now and we're almost
done with it
um this is the only debt we've ever had
that's really impressive okay so let's
recap here what John is saying is what
we teach folks to do and it is relative
to your question is to be gazelle
intense in baby steps one through three
and that's just wide open scorched Earth
no life totally getting out of debt
until you're debt free everything but
the house and until you have your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses in you've passed that when you
get to baby step four and start putting
15 of your income into retirement and
you start saving for kids college and
you maybe step six is extra money on the
house we move from intense to
intentional
and uh and so we that's when we slow
down we buy a couch or we upgrade the
car we go on vacation we and that all of
those things cost money so it slows down
the debt reduction but we're still very
careful very intentional very wise we
now can go out to eat but when you're in
those first three steps you're not doing
any of those things you're just a game
on right so you blew past that and just
stayed in intense mode is what you're
saying but you're within 10 months and
you're 23 so you're going to live
through it
right but also you got married at 21
your sweet wife married you at 21 and
and it says on our screen this is
affecting your marriage so what's going
on yeah y'all haven't been able to go
out to eat yet or anything what's going
on
uh yeah I think it's just we're so
intense uh focused on it uh we've kind
of forgotten to take a date night every
once in a while or
uh do any kind of extracurricular
activities because you know every penny
that we got we're trying to put it
towards the mortgage payment stop yeah
quit stop okay take 20 months and pay
off the house instead of 10. take your
wife out and by the way the idea that
you can't go do something without money
isn't true either y'all can go hiking
y'all can go out y'all can go walk by
the river you can do all kinds of things
for free but the idea that we're not
going to do anything together we're not
gonna have date night in our new
marriage because we got to do this thing
that's our recipe for this thing ending
up in Ash
who's the who's the fired up one you or
her
uh both of us actually but honestly yeah
it's probably just me
for the most part
it's for sure both of us and by both of
us I mean just me
yeah okay okay so if we listen if we
backed off on the OT but maybe it didn't
stop at all
but back down on it and we train change
the schedule to 20 months from 10 months
you're still going to be very wealthy
you're still going to have a great life
and that gives you some margin time wise
and money wise to have a good date night
that you actually spend money on to uh
plan a weekend away vacation to do some
other stuff you can start to build some
other things into your budget because
you're not doing scorched Earth anymore
because you shouldn't be really at this
stage it's not what we teach people to
do it's not evil it's not horrible that
you're doing it if you're both in
agreement and you just 10 more months
that's fine but that's not the case
right now you kind of got some Frayed
Ends on the Rope right now right
exactly yeah so just take them you don't
have to announce to your boss anything
just go you know boss I just can't take
as much overtime I'm going to spend a
little more time at home after all after
all I am a newlywed and I would here's
what I would do Jeremy if I'm you this
is the exact conversation I would have I
take my wife out I'd say hey we're gonna
go grab something and I will have
surprised her with somewhere that's a
little bit nicer and I would start the
conversation with
I have scorched Earth so I'm paying this
house off in the first two years I don't
want to get it paid off
but I haven't done a good job of dating
my wife and so I want to come up with a
plan that once a week you and I can go
do something doesn't have to be
extravagant but let's put something on
the books every single week what would
you like that to look like
and then after her jaw comes off the
floor then shut up and listen just be
quiet yes exactly exactly and it might
be it might be going out to dinner might
be going for a walk it might just be you
sitting on the couch putting your feet
up and not working 24 7 365. because
sometimes to a new spouse that can feel
like you're running from her and you're
trying to avoid her and when you're
trying to do the best you can it's just
aligning pictures and words all that but
I would sit down and take her to dinner
and say
I need to do a better job of dating my
wife because I love you like spending
time with you what would you like that
to look like yeah
okay and put it on the calendar and put
it in the budget
these things don't accidentally happen
as a philosophy they happen when you
tactically implement them
okay yeah and you don't tell your boss
anything except I don't want as many
hours yeah I wouldn't be in the I just
don't have as many hours I don't need as
many hours and then when the house is
paid off if you don't want to work if
you only want to work 40 that's fine I
don't need as many hours right and if
you want to go save up for something and
I work some hours then go work some
hours but that's okay
uh all of that's fine I don't think you
have to have a big explanation there in
fact I wouldn't and I also want to put
this out there if you're 23 24 and you
have the opportunity to work like crazy
you don't have kids yet
it's a good time to do it it's a great
time so maybe cut back from 60 to 50.
and take some over time yeah I didn't I
just like cut it off yeah I know but
it's easy to just if you break listen
the schedule that guy's on yeah he could
cut it back it's going to feel like
Nirvana yeah and he's still going to be
working more than most people his age
you know and let me just tell you
America here's what we know
we are sure because we see the data and
we talked to Jeremy's All Over America
we have the anecdotal evidence because
of our discussions with the marketplace
and actual research and data that gen Z
the 23 24 year old might be the hardest
working generation to come along in a
long time the ones that work
the ones that don't
are the most useless generation ever
there is no middle ground with Gen Z's
and Millennials they are either game on
Crusaders the best hard workers you'll
ever have I got a building full of them
I love them as an employer I love this
generation or they're completely
freaking useless
that's where they are and so and
everybody's picking up the news is
picking up on the useless ones the
participation trophy crowd and all that
crap and quiet quitting and all that
garbage no there's people like Jeremy
out there that that kid Works she's
about to have a paid off House of 23.
yeah well tell me this generation
doesn't know how to work they do this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here hey if
you're enjoying the show well you can
help us out we don't spend a lot of
money marketing like uh like we don't
have our own football stadium like uh so
far or something like that we don't we
don't do that but you're our marketing
and so if you want to um help us we'd
appreciate it you share the show share
the link on the show tell people where
you watch or listen to the show but
click the Subscribe and the follow
button and leave a five star review mama
said if you ain't got anything nice to
say don't say anything at all so no need
to leave one star if you don't think
that well of the show just listen to
something else it's okay
but there's a whole bunch of you out
there about 25 million of you so thank
you and you are telling people about the
show and you are sharing the show it's
showing up everywhere a lot of questions
this week about taxes because next
week's the week we got a file it's
confusing one of our listeners says Dave
what happens if I can't afford to pay my
taxes
uh
you go to jail they arrest you actually
they do but um but we're that's that's
not the correct answer of the question
but April because because we're not
going to do nothing okay you okay when
you say you can't afford to pay your
taxes
that's wrong okay because
if you have taxes it's because you have
an income and your taxes are not greater
than your income correct so you can
afford to pay your taxes you just have
to prioritize taxes before anything else
and I do I pay my taxes immediately uh
do not pass go do not collect 200 so
number one you've got to make it a
bigger priority and if you've gotten
behind because you're like you're
self-employed you didn't pay your
quarter lease and you got a big Bill
coming to or something like that and you
can't afford to pay that on April 18th
this year then that's a different kind
of I can't afford but I can't afford
period okay so if that's the case what
you always do is you always file on time
they actually will not put you in jail
for failure to pay they will put you in
jail for failure to file uh okay
2579 people went to jail last year
really failure to file federal income
tax it is a it is a federal law so file
even if you don't pay okay file your
taxes and then call them and get on a
payment plan with them it's horrible the
the interest rate's ridiculous and the
uh penalties are ridiculous and all that
but you know you start paying a few
dollars a month you can keep them at Bay
for a very very long time while you get
your crap together and just get them
paid off but ignoring them is not an
option let me just tell you most things
that you ignore that are bad get worse
correct when you ignore them taxes
get worse 10x if you ignore them they
get nastier meaner not filing not paying
not being on a plan not developing some
way to get the KGB I mean the IRS out of
your ear hole is not a good idea you've
got to deal with this you've got to deal
with it anybody that doesn't deal with
problems has bigger problems and the IRS
is a super big example of that I am not
scared of the IRS and I am not a
promoter of the IRS neither one they
hate me because I make fun of them they
love me because I tell people to pay
their taxes number one it's a matter of
Integrity number two it's the law number
three you're gonna screw up your life
running from these people so you don't
want to do that so if you set up a
payment plan and you're paying 200 a
month and you owe them four thousand
dollars then go get you five jobs and
pay the four thousand dollars right now
right do it right now
like yesterday
and uh
and figure out what caused you to get
behind in the first place and don't ever
do that again so that you're never here
again so it is one of the worst
uh bills one of the worst debts that you
can have
because the interest and the penalties
are so high and they have almost
unlimited power to get to get your butt
in trouble so not dealing with it is the
worst possible thing you can do file on
time even if you can't pay filing an
extension does not extend your re your
demand to pay if you owe a thousand
dollars and you file an extension and
you don't pay the thousand dollars
you're going to get penalized and tax
and interest on all that so you do not
you have to pay even if you file an
extension if you if you have the money
so don't pay something else but pay
these people
there's no I mean being behind on your
credit card
being behind on the IRS that is a bad
idea
there you go so if you need some help
with taxes go to Ramsey smart tax we can
help you we've got a an online filing
software that's very inexpensive to use
get filed if you've got a problem like
this you could get with a tax
professional if you've got a complicated
return you can get with a tax
professional
ramseysolutions.com smarttax or get one
of the elps that if you've got a
complicated situation they can help you
guys do not ignore the tax thing
and I guess the last thing we'll add one
more time because we talk about it all
the time is if you're getting a refund
stop being stupid
you should not be getting a refund
a re-fund is what you get when you take
a shirt back to the store and they give
you your money back
that's what a refund is they're giving
you your money back you've paid too much
in to the IRS
it's still your money it's not magical
it's kind of like you know you ever put
20 in a coat and forget it and next
winter you put the coat on I feel like I
won something and put your hand you got
twenty dollars what was your twenty
dollars stupid but it's been in the coat
all winter why are you why you're so
excited you know that's the same thing
as a tax refund it's exactly the same
deal okay so you just it's it you have a
savings account with a government that
pays no interest dumb Santa Claus is old
like me I know him personally he does
not live in Washington DC as a matter of
fact he doesn't even like going to
Washington DC because there's so few
good boys and girls there it's it does
it is painted like the government's
hooking you up it's like we love you so
much here's a check we're gonna increase
your refund this year
which means they're going to increase
how much that you overpaid
that's what that is so it's dumb don't
do that
Amber Amber is with us in Washington D.C
one of the good boys and girls in
Washington DC hey Amber how are you
I'm doing good how are you better than I
deserve what's up so
um just to keep it short I'm about 30 I
did the calculations I'm about 38 000 in
debt that includes a 24
000 car loan
um a 7600 credit card that's one credit
card and a six thousand dollar personal
loan
um due to my separation it has caused me
to be in debt I got separated last year
um husband kind of left me and our three
children with nothing just the car which
is why I took out a personal loan to put
a down payment on the car
um then you bought a car you couldn't
afford
how much do you make kiddo
annually my take home is about
000.
um and last year it was way less than
that so
um
left it broke your heart
and you were living in a fog and you
made a major mistake
you bought it you bought a car you
bought a car that you cannot afford and
the car is killing you
it is my monthly payment for that car is
by like 570 a month
um you know I'm afloat on everything but
um you're barely making it I'm not I
nothing is behind but you know yeah but
you're barely I mean you can't breathe
yeah you can't breathe yeah I cannot I'm
so sorry um I'm sorry honey okay here's
what we're gonna do yeah
we're gonna do we're gonna help you okay
I'm gonna put you in our non-week class
Financial Peace University I'm gonna pay
for it
okay and I'm gonna set you up with a
coach
that's going to walk with you and help
you get this mess cleaned up because
I've been where you are where I'm too
scared to think and you're not thinking
you've got to get rid of this car and
get your cheap car that you pay cash for
it's gonna be hard but we'll walk you
through how to do it because this is not
sustainable and let me say this I hear
you wanting to explain but before this
everything was okay and
you you're not a bad person and you
didn't you're not a failure
you just made a mistake and your husband
left you he walked away
so there's nothing to apologize let's
look forward and let's get this mess
cleaned up moving forward yeah learn
from the mistake and never do it again
so we will walk with you we'll help you
I'm gonna put a coach in your corner I'm
gonna pay for it we're gonna put you in
Financial Peace University I'm gonna pay
for it you don't have to pay anything
all you got to do is do the hard work
kiddo we'll walk with you and you call
us anytime you need help but what
that'll get you started because you've
got a complicated situation we can't fix
on the radio today this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author host of
the Dr John deloney show on podcast a
Ramsey Network experience don't miss all
of that you don't miss any of it in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Paul is with us hey Paul how
are you hey hey Dave how are you doing
better than I deserve man where do you
live I live in Somerville New Jersey
cool welcome to Nashville thank you how
much debt have you paid off Paul a
hundred and ten thousand dollars wow wow
good for you how long did that take 44
months wow and your range of income
during that time uh when I first began
it was 70 000 and I'm now at 105 000.
cool what do you do for a living I'm a
senior data engineer for a healthcare
technology company wow good for you
great job good good good good good good
okay so a hundred and ten thousand
dollars was what kind of debt a hundred
of it was student debt and 10
000 of that was a credit card okay
would you get a degree in uh my
undergrad was mathematics and my
Master's was in business business
analysis good good for you very cool so
about uh four years ago or so something
clicked and you said I got to get this
paid off what happened
um so we actually need to go back to
2017 February 4th of 2017 uh that day uh
I left a domestic violent uh
relationship
um my life was threatened
um and I had to leave with
nothing but my clothes on my back and my
book bag wow and came and I went back
home
um and so I went through therapy and
through therapy me and my therapist
worked together to make a game plan and
that was October of 2018 I actually have
my uh the notes in my back pocket uh it
was October 27 2018
and we made a game plan to
Envision a life without debt because
um Not only was I physically abused
emotionally abused I was financially
um I allowed for my student loans to go
into default and I rigged up credit card
debt
um
and so uh 29 so because my loans went
into default
um I worked in 2019 to uh to get them
back into standing Grace
um and then 2020 then uh 2020 came and
the interest rate went down to zero
and game on that yeah exactly yeah
um it sounds like you really uh went
through an amazing healing process and
that this this therapist did a really
good job yeah she uh very much believed
in me uh I tell you what I I I'm so
dumbfounded that you found
an incredible therapist because most
therapists are going to I don't say most
the ethos around the field sometimes is
wow look what happened to you and your
therapist said okay we got this Giant
mountain we're going to work together
and we're going to climb this mountain
we're going through this storm we're not
going to sit here and travel around it's
incredible your therapist is a hero and
you are a hero for following the plan
thank you and uh Jonathan I could say uh
in that meeting on 10 27 2018 her words
to me were if you're not uh if you don't
do it no one else will and that that
struck a court that struck a chord and
because
um and Calvary is not coming I
um in um in my time in um
and my domestically violent situation uh
there were times that I did live in the
red
um there were times that
um I didn't know where my next paycheck
was yeah but you taking control of all
these different components of your life
was your healing Journey yes that was so
because you instead of being a victim
you took you became a Victor yes you got
hero status and took control of each of
these different areas and said okay
that's not me that's not me that's not
me I'm a guy who pays this stuff off and
you reset your identity and took off man
very good work how does it feel right
now oh man you're amazing
um to think that uh so when my loans
came out of default which was February
of 20 of 2020 which was literally a
month before
the national
um uh we uh
I was literally on 90 000 and then
literally the week before Christmas
I paid my last of this past year in 2022
I paid off my last student student loans
and I feel
Overjoyed yeah when you watch this back
when you watch this YouTube clip I want
you to look at your shoulders and your
body posture when you're talking about
your past and then look at yourself
right now man like your whole everything
about you is different that's amazing
thank you John you changed the way you
were standing when you're talking about
it it's pretty impressive pretty cool
thank you very cool so proud of you man
thank you Dave very very well done all
right one more time I want America to
hear what your therapist said
on in October of 17 or October of 18.
she said
Paul if you don't uh if you don't do
this no one else will okay people in
case you think Joe Biden's gonna pay
your debt there's your answer if you
don't do this no one else will
I love you I'll help you I'll kick your
butt I'll hug your neck I'll be there
with you I'm not paying your freaking
debt if you don't do this no one else
will Paul's got the formula Paul did it
Paul did it I love it I love this guy
and I love it you're a math major and
the math didn't matter here because the
math said it's zero percent it's not
adding up let's just put it aside and
you went with the heart route you said
I'm getting the stuff off my chest I'm
going you don't do this you don't want
else will I'm so proud of you man it's
amazing welcome to your life thank you
if you don't fix it no one else is going
to man how good does it feel to be free
oh and Powerful Dave took the words
right out of my mouth like it
yeah I have a new I have a new life
um a life that compared to where I was
to where I am right now it it's yeah no
words can no words can explain yeah
powerful man so powerful
all right now when someone says to you
how did you pay off a hundred and ten
thousand dollars what do you tell them
the key to getting out of debt is
consistency
um
uh
um there were times like there were
times last year last year alone I paid
45 000 in debt and
I had to sacrifice a few things a trip
here trip there
um you sacrificed a lot Paul it's okay
to say it you sacrificed a lot
but it was worth it I sacrificed
contributing to my 401k for one year
yeah
um and that
uh equal to even more money going
towards my student debt and
um
I like just to say if anyone's
it's Poss it's possible yeah um it may
seem like a mountain
but
once you get it going
you see the little victories and then
you see it gone forever
and then before you know it all of it's
gone amen
hey we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you latest number one
bestseller Because You're Gonna Be A
Millionaire thank you that's where
you're going thank you and we got a copy
of Total Money Makeover for you to give
to someone else and give them the hope
that you found uh the same with the
Financial Peace University membership
all of that is the live and give box and
you can live with some of it give some
of it pay it forward you're amazing so
proud of you thank you great great story
uh hats off to your therapist a great
job by a professional doing what they're
supposed to do helping you own this and
taking control the secret to getting out
of debt people is
nobody's coming
you're gonna have to do it that's a
secret as soon as you realize that then
all of a sudden the math start working
this amazing thing how that happened
it's just amazing the calvary is not
coming over the hill I don't care if you
hear trumpets or not it's not a Calvary
they're not coming you have to do this
Paul from
44 months making 70 to 105. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one I'm debt free
[Music]
[Applause]
love it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our scripture today is Proverbs 24 16
for the righteous falls seven times and
rises again but the wicked stumble in
times of calamity
Alice Cooper said mistakes are part of
the game it's how well you recover from
them that is the mark of a great player
Ben is in Knoxville hey Ben welcome to
the Ramsay show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up um I have wanted I wanted to ask uh
what your thoughts were on fractional
real estate investing I've noticed
there's uh been kind of a trend towards
that and uh in a couple apps that offer
that and I know um that uh real estate
is there there's a shortage in houses
overall and you don't advise for getting
into debt so I don't I just wanted to
hear your thoughts on
um
on all this stuff yeah well in terms of
buying rental property I would buy it
and pay cash and own it or I wouldn't do
it uh I wouldn't do fractional if you if
you are not in a position to buy real
estate and that's why fractional seems
appealing to you then what I would look
into is if you're at that stage and the
baby steps to do investing you can look
into an Reit a real estate investment
trust it's basically functions like a
mutual fund that buys real estate
and so you get the marketplace benefits
the returns of owning real estate
managing real estate uh but you can buy
into it with a few dollars like you
would with a mutual fund I mean you get
a mutual fund for a thousand twenty five
hundred five thousand bucks you can get
in REITs for the same kind of money and
you can pick those up with your smart
investor Pro in the old days like when I
first started this show REITs were new
and uh they were they were they were
killing their uh stockholders with or
their their shareholders with fees and
so the net returns to the shareholders
weren't very good they weren't keeping
up with growth stock mutual funds today
the better REITs the good ones are are
getting comparable returns to good
growth stock mutual funds so you're
gonna see 10 12 14 rates of return uh in
a Reit and if you're not in a position
to pay cash which is driving your
fractional discussion then um the
problem with fractional is it is that
you don't have any control
and you're you know for instance I
talked to a friend of mine today looking
at us buying into a small business and
he was going to own 40 percent
you're what's called a minority
shareholder which also translated means
you're up a creek
because you have absolutely they can
they can run the thing in the ground
they can make all kinds of bad decisions
and you can't do anything about it
because you can't outvote them and
that's what you got with fractional they
could run the property poorly they could
choose the property poorly they could
sell the property at the wrong time for
too little and you got no say
there's very fractionals just I'm not a
fan hey when you own real estate
depending on which
um Instagram you're following at 3am one
will tell you the point is cash flow one
will tell you the point is somebody else
pays off the debt is the equity
on a teeter-totter what's more important
this cash flow that these properties
produce over time or the equity they
produce uh as the house goes up in value
or maybe I've made the most money on
appreciation okay on the equity yeah the
increase in values okay increase in
values
um I make good money on the cash flows
and uh there's basically three places
you make a rate of return in real estate
you the increase in value the cash flow
and uh the tax advantage because you can
appreciate them right so you're
Sheltering some of the income so those
three things actually create an actual
dollar return to you uh of course the
appreciation you do not realize until
you sell the house so you don't you know
if you've got a house you bought a house
for a half million it goes to two
million you don't get that million and a
half until you sell it so uh but those
three things together in real estate are
calculated in what's called an irr an
internal rate of return okay and uh it's
all three of those components
mathematically added together and on a
piece of residential my typical
residential our cash flow eight or ten
percent
and uh so and I'm the total value yeah
okay yeah my irr on that thing no of
what I paid for it or no total value uh
I'm probably uh cash flowing a lot more
than I want to paid for it but the uh my
irr over a 20-year holding periods
probably 17 or 18 okay so that's
probably what I'm making on it total
okay but uh uh but uh again it's not I'm
not I'm not putting that in my pocket
today so uh so real estate's a little
different in that regard
um and there you go okay Andrea is with
us in Fort Myers hey Andrea welcome to
the Ramsey Show
thank you I have a quick question how
many grandparents are having my mother
the executor of their will they live in
a different state does it make sense for
my mother to have her name on their bank
accounts for seamlessness or not until
the time comes
it wouldn't hurt uh how old are they
they're in their 80s yeah I would
and the only reason is this it
absolutely affects nothing except okay
if both of them passed away and her name
is not on the account she has to go to
the court right quick to get control of
enough money to begin to run the estate
and she's the executor of the estate
okay it just makes it it adds a step and
it it makes the first two weeks
following death more clunky
okay and but I wouldn't do this if you
were 52.
you're 82 though the people we're
talking about okay
and I'm not I'm not suggesting they're
gonna pass away this year but they're
more likely to statistically than a 52
year old I'm 63 the executor I'm 62 the
executor on my estate is not on my
checking account
okay sure well actually she is because
Sharon but if we both died the third the
third party if we both died in a car
wreck tomorrow uh the the executor isn't
the third party executor is not on the
account that's not what they're not
what's happening so uh all of that to
say uh you know when
when we are approaching the end of life
either because of uh statistically
because of age which we can say that in
the 80s okay or you know you're you're
fighting a a terminal cancer diagnosis
or something like that then yeah go
ahead and put the executor on there
because it's going to make the first
three weeks following death much uh much
smoother
does that make sense
are you there
not there okay that works too but that's
it so I you're not supposed to say
people die but anyway they do they do I
say it all the time though they do they
do 100 of them done 100 detailed
research you're not getting out of this
life 100 something um I actually I
actually like this Dave I've just sat
with people who
um somebody loves they love passed away
and their job is to handle what happens
next and man having to go through a
court system to get your name on a
checking account such a pain just have
it on there it's great yeah
yeah just uh but you don't have to do
that 25 years in advance either that's
weird clunky and weird and not respond I
mean you know so if something happened
to share me today they'd have the clunky
that's right uh but life happens there
but on this one but yeah where you're
dealing with uh people in the in the
later Decades of life life
but the uh
God or the uh uh or or you're looking at
a terminal illness or something like
that that's when you would do that kind
of thing so yeah that that's that does
make sense in her case that's what I
would do but it's not a it's just a it's
not a philosophical thing it's not a a
principle that if you don't do this
you've done it wrong it's just tactical
like you know you just got access to the
money to pay the funeral home you know
you got to access the money to uh take
care of the light bill at the house that
didn't get paid that month well
hopefully it's part of a grander
conversation about ham this old now I'm
I'm gonna go ahead and park the car and
I'm this old now and I want to review
the will with you and I'm this old now
and I'm gonna go ahead and put you in
the checking account as a due diligence
you're gonna love the people who your
family members that you're leaving
behind so much that you're going to get
over your fear and over the awkwardness
of having these conversations and you're
going to make sure everybody's on the
same page it is the most functional
relational functional thing that a
family can do such a gift and uh the
more dysfunctional the family the less
likely that is that they're going to do
this and they're the ones that really
need to do it because if you're going to
piss somebody off in your will you ought
to do it while you're alive at least you
get that's the only way you get the
benefit right yeah you can tell them
about it and you just go you're on
cocaine you're getting nothing you know
let's just go ahead and tell them now so
they can be pissed now I mean by the way
I told Sheila I said I want my funeral
to be like this and she said I'm not
doing chores for you and you're dead
when you're gone
so there you go that puts us out where
the Rams are showing the book so we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]